this is a production of Cornell
University well welcome everyone thank
you for joining us it's a really special
seminar today and I'm really happy to be
hosting visitors um and I really wish we
could have one plant breeding seminar
per visitor because the wealth of
information and experience of the people
who are here for the next two weeks I'll
talk about is enormous but we don't have
time so we're just going to have a panel
discussion everybody's going to get to
share kind of their experience
um and just to say that we're lucky that
everybody's here today us visas have
been very difficult so we put together
Workshop it's taking a long time so
appreciating the effort that went into
that so today with us we have everybody
will introduce themselves but I'll just
briefly give names so Sophia divage
Evelyn Luis and
Simon um so together I just want to set
the scene for why we're here some of you
who came to Martina's talk last week may
have heard about the Innovation lab for
crop Improvement she mentioned some
collaborative work work there so the
Innovation lab for crop Improvement is a
feed the future program and we really
work with national agricultural research
institutes globally On Tools
Technologies and methods that increase
Effectiveness and impact from crop
reading programs so that's kind of the
central man and there's many programs
that we engage with I'm not going to go
into the details but just point out four
centers of innovation these are nodes
where a lot of the research takes place
the first is syphus based with nari and
Uganda with collab ations in Kenya and
Tanzania the second one is cesa that's
centered in Malawi at luanar with
collaborations in Tanzania and
Mozambique and in West Africa we have
siwa that's centered in Sagal with
collaborations in Nigeria and Bina
fossil and lastly in uh the Caribbean in
Central America we have katcha that's a
collaboration with casaya University in
Haiti and Inta and Costa Rico So within
all of those breeding programs across
multiple crops there are social
scientists doing work with the breeding
programs to really reorient to make sure
their breeding is socially impactful and
considering different issues so there's
a group of us and we work under what's
called priority setting and crosscutting
issues cross cutting issues are gender
equality youth inclusion nutrition
resilience and inclusion more broadly so
a lot of we're a group of social
scientists kind of working across those
domains and we really generate knowledge
but also tools and methods to help diet
breeding program so today you'll hear a
little bit about the experience not only
on this project but beyond the project
um so I'm going to start us off with
introductions and I'll just start
directly from you you're okay that okay
thank you very much want to lean a
little
bit thank you very much uh
Hal uh I'm happy to be here I'm called H
Sophia from
Uganda I work for the national
agriculture research organization
uh the national agriculture
organization has a
mandate of conducting research in
Uganda uh research on differing on crops
livestock
Fisheries uh Agro forestry among others
so um I'm based at uh we have 16
institutions in the whole country and
I'm based in the Eastern side of Uganda
where we work on um uh Dryland
crops and uh as far as cphims is
concerned uh we are targeting okay the
project is on finger Millet and
soam and these two projects I mean these
two cops are under Dryland crops in
Uganda so
uh I work as a social
Economist and uh actually my mandate is
mainly to evaluate the Technologies
developed by
breeders and uh we work hand in
hand uh this project uh its uh main
objective is to
accelerate uh development and release of
finger Millet and uh so
varieties of which as a social
Economist um I have to conduct some work
on trade preference to inform the
Breeders on which trades are preferred
by Farmers so I'm glad to be here at
Cornell I'm very happy to meet my
colleagues who are also working in Cross
cutting and priority setting teams
uh we shall share a
loot and uh also share the experiences
from the different
countries thank you very much thank
you good afternoon everyone my name is
belash I'm from
mozambik I work for the national
agriculture Research
Institute mainly on Lum National Lum
crop uh program for the scope of this
project we are working on copy on
Crossing and PRI issues and I'm happy to
be here and share what we are doing
thank
you okay hi everyone I'm Evelyn comp so
I come from West Africa Bina
Faso and I by training I did science
technology and Innovation studies in
sociology and social policy and I work
for the National Institute for
agriculture and environment based in
Bina Faso like what my colleague was
saying we have like 10
different sections throughout the
country and I'm in the central part is
the biggest Center in the country and uh
I also teach at the University of Joseph
keru in Bina Faso I teach like action
research and I also teach a so
development sociology modules at the
University and at inera I work I got a
let's say is a large team but in the
central part we we got part of the team
looking at Cross cutting related issue
which is mostly socio economic studies
and also gender related issue because
socio economy is big and inside social
economy we have some sometimes to look
at disaggregated information based on
gender or based on age and Etc and uh we
work on so many aspects in got many
departments among the department we have
the breeding Department we have soil
scientist we have geography Department
we have also social scientist and I must
say on breeding we go we do breeding in
most of the crop like uh I would say
rice and Maze which are the main crops
which have received quite lot of funds
in the past and in the case of ilc the
the project we are collaborating with
colel and my colleagues here we focus on
CI which is a the most famous legum in
bukina it used to be women crop and it
turned out to become a cash crop so mens
are taking the lead and we have also
millets and sorum and also ground nuts
part of these crops and I just want to
say that among these crops as breeding
we also do breeding on vegetables and
also like tomatoes onion but this part
is quite for now is an ongoing work and
other vegetables and also the dry crops
I just named I wouldn't say they
neglected because now they're coming up
very well and lot of effort have been
doing by funders and research on this
level so I should say I am so pleased to
be here and sitting in front here to
talk about my experience and also the
experience as a group in the project and
as a researcher in West Africa yeah
where agriculture is the main source of
Revenue and also the main source of
living everyday life thank you so
much good afternoon can you hear me yeah
yes okay thank you very much I am glad
to be here with our my colleagues I am
from Costa Rica in Central America a
small country
and I am part of Casia Central American
and Caribbean growth Improvement is a
project that we ER make with Kisa
University in it I am part of um
National research of agriculture in
Costa Rica that is part of minister of
Agriculture um in in this project in CIA
we are working in three crops in sorum
in Comm bean that is part a very
important part of the our food in Costa
Rica and in in in sweet
potato
and part of my job in this in this
project like a social economic a
agriculture economic we are working on
uh three three um Reserve activity H now
we are in a
um participative evaluation with a
method that we are working with with ilc
that is the triode in
surum and we are making in a couple of
months we are going to make a
fingerprinting
um H fingerprinting
for evaluate our common being
um reading
program and that is part what I what
that my team is is working on now in in
in this project and it's it's a pleasure
to be
here hi everyone my name is Simon Ami I
come from Kenya I work for the
organization called Kenya Agricultural
and livestock
organization I'm a researcher by
profession I'm a value chain
specialist and at Caro our mandate is to
be able to disseminate new Innovations
on crop Improvement livestock natural
resource management and social science
research uh I'm happy to be part of this
uh
eminent uh team and uh in the project
which is supported by ilc uh we are
working on social
inclusion uh for food
security and incomes and increasing the
voice of marginalized farmers in
Kenya uh more about it uh in the next
session thank
Youk thank you so much everyone for
introducing yourselves and welcome again
um so we're going to have two sets of
questions and then open question and
answer at the end so we're going to
start with with going to ask um three
panelists to give examples where some of
their work has been impactful in
informing the breeding program just to
give you an example of what this looks
like in action right um G start with
Louise okay
yeah okay thank you very much this is a
a a simple um example um I have to give
you a little context about it
ER these project are very helpful for us
we have to be very strategic because we
have we don't have enough time for a
plan breing process we have just we need
our our process in planing take like six
or eight years and this project is about
three years so we have to be very smart
and strategic to to try to to to adopt
the technology that ELC provide us and
try to to to go the goals right so H we
have
um six no five prising lines materials
of common Red Pins it's okay and this
these six um these five H lines come
from a um breathing process that take
like six years it stting in 200 7th this
lines H was evaluating in um farmer
fields and this is the and we are we
just need er a validating process to
release one VAR right
H with Casia we we decide to change a
little bit the
things to give some ch methods with a
with a plant
breeding
um the the the way that they made this
this this this validation in the
past ER they select some Farmers that
they trust like
and H we talk to to to the to the plb
and told him that H change a little bit
the things
and a random randoms randomize the the
sample right and increase the sum to try
to incor to to to add to the to the to
the selection another ER another context
another Farmers
right the plant breeders of course they
have the favorite Varity at this part at
the end
a I'm going to tell you that the name is
the the SEF 64 that is the the name of
that that that material but we have five
right and they discard is that the right
they
discard they have the top and the last
one was the se71 right so we we we give
this
recommendation a small recommendation a
simple recommendation to this to this to
these H colleagues just to to prove we
know some things about the context that
the market Chang a little bit we we
studied
this before this this recommendation of
course because this St money there is a
lot of budget in this in this
process ER and we have the collaboration
of course
the a um a student of PhD of Cornell
that is Sergio Puerto I have to to add
this information sorry but ER in this um
in this group we realize that um H we
made that the procedure we made the we
use the triot method that is a triadic
comparation of Technology at the end is
a massive evaluation we made this
process in 400 fields in Costa Rica in
the two region of commercial
production and erh at the end of this
this process we we know that the
favorite of and the the aage favorite um
Varity was the se71 right that uh how to
say that the difference between the
people who the plant breed right ER we
Pro our hypothesis because the market
changed a little bit in Costa Rica and
in in the last 10 years because the
government
um the government ER go to the market
and
buy common bin for the ER company of the
of the government right you know ER
hospitals uh schools all so they the
government was part an important part of
the market right and they changed a
little bit
conditions in the past the condition was
the industry put his opinion over the
trait that the farmer select right we
know this with a small H
quality sessions
so
er we want to know that H and we we we
received this this feedback so of course
H this is
a a a
it's not a structural situation it's a
um how to say that there is it's not a
structural is more specific a specific
ER situation right because ER it depend
of the government but they give know uh
the this this process procedure give us
uh a feedback to select not one priority
not two priorities one for the
government and the other one for the
industry there is two important markets
and
that's
a in the that's our experience a small
change a decision randomize that's all
what what we do change
a um the the situation and now I I got
some information and this new Varity
that we released in this years we're
expecting to re to to release the other
one but this Varity that is for
government er er they are starting very
well ER like five ,000 of
um
er I forgot the the measure
the five five th000
um
sorry the measure of no
it's no Quint qu thank you very much
5,000 Kint that that means like
5,000 hectares is is planting this this
this new er er harvest season and for
this this new Varity so that's our
experience there is a small change that
we that we introduce in our process and
make a difference in the results that is
my experience I don't know if you
understand very well I'm sorry about my
rough English
but but I am glad if I send you the
right message for our experience thank
you yes yes yes thank you everyone once
again so now in advance my apologies
about my English also is not good um
from the where I come from we don't
speak English we speak
Portuguese so C in MO most likely in
southern region is a widely grown
crop with with the time a lot of
research has been conducted on that crop
which has result as well on variety
release as well as aonic practice which
related to those
but again the adoption rate either from
the varities or the AG agic practice or
packages is not as as
desired many factors can can can explain
that that reason but one of them is most
likely lack
of involvement within the
disciplines I mean social part of the
the research as well of the VAR
development itself I I I want say the
breeding
so as a study was conducted for Value
chain analysis on on C value chain in in
mic so among various findings
that were generated from from that
stud one of the thing
that it's really important that it has
helped to
uh to improve I mean I could say the
integration of the social aspects on the
breeding component was that as a result
of that study was possible to
identify ER Market
segmentations according to the ER
Farmers description and the traits of
Interest or desired traits from from or
prefer threat I think it's correct
prefer threat from from the
farmer just to mention the market
segmentations that the they were
identified from that stud one is for dry
grain for exportation okay that's one of
the mark segmentation the second one is
also uh for food
processing okay and then the third one
is more food security related which has
to do with the international for for
international market as well as local
consumption uh because this this third
one has comprised in terms of
a traits that the the variety that
respond to that market segmentation has
to have dual purpose on which is
possible to get used from the lifs and
then get use of the poorts either uh
fresh pots and as well of grain grain
dry grain for from the international
market
so with that
information ER the breeding the cop
breeding program Now is working focus on
those three Market segmentation in such
a way that the crossing blocks that have
been conducted as specifically to
respond to those to those MA
segmentation so the buing program has
asper now uh if we go to the breeding
team they have got a Crossing block with
the parents identified to respond the
mark segmentation one there is a Closs
Crossing
block for the parents and the materials
uh that have been developed just to
respond to math segment to and for the
thir Market segmentation of course there
are specific traes for each market
segmentation for example for the as I
was saying for the mark segmentation
three that one of the the traes is a in
terms of duration is a medium to short
duration those are the tra has to be in
terms of seed color is important trait
that came out from that St that stud is
brown seed and as I said those are the
Vari for Dual Purpose on which the the
leaves can be used as well as the has
the has the
pots and grain can be consumed either
fresh or dried when it reach for for d
for the to respond to the export and
again just summarize just to to bring in
as an example on how
the the activities or the result from
the socio economic has impacted and
directing the breeding program contrary
for from the past on which the approach
was not necessarily guided for the
specific Market segment which are result
of a
a a scientific Bas if I can call that
way
and as per now uh we believe that that
that can be an strategy which can
improve the situation of
VAR of take or or or or R of adoption
this is also an experience okay for the
purpose of this project is is is been
done with C but there is experience
that our Institute wants to do across
other value chain or other commodity as
well uh so that the efforts resource uh
properly directed in order to to
immediately respond to the end users
needs or or preference so that's in
short how what we can bring in to to
share on
how or social aspect or or socio
economic aspect if I can call that has
impacted and directed The the breeding
program and in MO specifical breeding
program so one aspect that also comes
out is not
necessarily with
the soci economy the interdisiplinary
aspect has has has all that's one of the
lessons that can come out because
there's a lot of
disciplines which I believe the goal is
the same to have a product that better
responds to the end
users thank you very much right thank
you
okay thank you very much um I would like
to also share the experience from
Uganda and um for us from our breeding
program actually I can say that this is
now a positive that we have changed from
top
down um reading approach to demand
driven reading approach whereby we have
to listen to our
customers and these customers I look we
look at them uh through okay we follow
the value chain at different we look at
different nodes what do producers want
what do uh processors want Traders and
consumers so that I think by doing this
we we can succeed that at the end of the
day we shall come up with a product
which is really demanded and the
adoption rate will go high uh so uh what
we have done uh first of all we have
mared all okay like the stakeholders
along the value chain the Millet and
soan value
chain uh we get to know who who are our
customers what do they want want which
varieties are they interested in and why
so I think we have all these answers
because we have already conducted the
the studies and we have the reports out
so after
that uh we conducted um we analyzed the
data and uh we came up with product
profiles uh we have
the targeted product profiles for the
different market segments uh for example
for sug we have three market segments
which we are following and uh this one
we have Brewer rary industry we have the
food industry and the beverage the soft
drink so
um uh the same applies to finger Millet
because the way finger millet that is
utilized is almost the same way so is
utilized so um now the product profiles
we had to discuss the product profiles
with the Breeders to agree because uh
there are some you see like there are
some traits which are coming up strongly
and uh yet breeders say we can't breed
for this but Farmers want them
so we have to discuss and see what can
we do for such
cases um now uh after presenting this
actually we have the final product
profiles which we shared with uh
breeders the Breeders are using theyve
already used these product Prof
especially for finger Millet to select
because actually for us I thought at
first that not until till the product
profile is out that's when the breeding
exercise will begin yet this the
Breeders already have their jum plasm so
when you present this they will just
select the varieties which align to to
the traits which which Farmers or which
the different stakeholders need so they
have already selected this G plasm and
we had to do
validation whereby um if we say for
example finger and soam are grown in
specific areas of eastern northern and
western Uganda so uh you see like in
each
region uh they they have different
traits which they prefer they are not
the same so you find that there are some
traits which cut across the
regions um
now what we did we
selected uh depending on the product
profiles the the jum plasm and evaluated
them with the farmers
still uh this time we didn't involve
other stakeholders we haven't involved
other stakeholders but we have evaluated
with farmers and sincerely what Farmers
for them they they static actually how
can I bring
it like their their choices don't keep
changing because we all we all know that
their choices are Dynamic sometimes the
consumers tell you today we need this
tomorrow they need another one but this
time around after validation we really
it came out that there are
consistent in their choice selection so
um I think uh what now we have to do is
to take out these
varieties to the farmers and other
stakeholders like the
consumers and the
processors uh the interesting bit as I
said that uh
breeders some sometimes they also have
their goals they have their objectives
why they
breeding so this time
around uh during the discussion AB will
tell you yes you are telling me that um
color is very important or
the uh there is a trait of is to thresh
especially for for for finger Millet you
know like finger Millet in Uganda we
call it a women's crop because uh men
don't like to to do it to cultivate
finger Millet they say it's really hard
it is it has a lot of work and uh like
when it comes to activities like
weeding men don't like bending that's
over bending they say for them their
backs pain the women at least for them
they can do that
so there are some traits which you think
they they're not very important but when
farmers are selecting these varieties
they really say we want a variety maybe
which which which
tills uh uh for reasons that it will
increase uh the production as well as
also reduce on the work of over weeding
like two three times so it suppresses
the what the weeds so some of these
traits and
then breeders say but this these are not
important traits yes you are saying they
are not important but farmers will not
will not adopt those varieties which you
think are very important so um what I've
realized that we have to listen to our
customers if your target is maybe to
breed
for the brewering company or you are
breeding for food can can you listen to
the customer who says I want a variety
which tastes like like this because when
you don't they will not adopt these
varieties uh we also realized during the
the survey
that um the variety the improved
varieties out there are not known
however sometimes you find that they
already with Farmers but uh in case h
takes a variety somewhere they will call
it hone they will not call
it yeah so uh they are not aware someone
is like you mean we have improved ulate
varieties so they are not aware that the
our Vari is are out there so we need to
do a lot of
awareness uh to these
Farmers so that I think they can the
demand can increase and this I think
affects the seed system if we don't do
so so um I think another thing which I
wanted to to share with you
[Music]
um
okay so
sorry too much to hear
about I want to make sure we hear from
EV and Simon too because we're running a
little bit low on time thank you um so
to evine and Simon they they're really
deeply involved in Social inclusion
related work so I just wanted to see why
is social inclusion important to your
work and you could talk about okay thank
you so much to for the floor I just want
before I start to set a bit the scene I
started with Ina is almost now 11 years
when I started and I went to two
workshop and when I people will joke
with you have you found what you are
searching what are you doing I say I'm a
researcher have you found what you are
searching and I look at the person and I
don't know what to answer the second
thing they would they would continue and
say oh like Sankar was saying researcher
who are searching we got them
the researcher who are finding we are
still searching for
them so and then I was like wow so this
is the world where I am I am putting my
foot
in and and there was a kind of saying
that we had Challenge and this was 2014
we had a a big challenge because we had
lot of varieties piled in the shelves
and they're not moving I mean they don't
go out
and we had like two or three story but
this was definitely real stories because
at the beginning were like yeah you you
close yourself in the lab you work hard
you come up with a variety because you
think that my community is dying from
Hunger if I got a variety which can
produce double of this because usually
it's half now if it this full they're
going to be happy and eat well and in
the end of the day you get the variety
it will go there for one year next year
you go there every just doing like
this or they will take it for respect
because you bring bring it to them but
they will never s it so it end up being
cooked these are seeds or if not be
cooked it will be probably sell to the
market or given to because it's not what
they're
expecting so and I think this was quite
lessons that breeding team has learned
and also and they realize that when I
enter I think I had one colleague who
was a sociologist and another two in the
center I was who were Economist and
other were doing the
PHD and it was like every it were like
two World everyone is in the corner
trying to do whatever they're trying to
do and we were call that is very urgent
that instead of waiting to fail and then
you call you please come you did soci
sociology come come and help me to
understand what is going on then you go
you do the survey they say oh I mean we
we don't like the this Crow because it's
too short the height is not what we
expecting or we need a market they need
to build a market for us and they will
go they will build the market and no one
is sitting in the market just because
they turn the shops toward this and in
the culture if the shop is toward this
end it means that you are going to
collapse so nobody is going to use this
market so it was definitely a big time
that things are done in a very inclusive
way from the beginning which means we
should not leave anyone outside I used
to tell my colleagues that it's like the
body if your you got your little finger
with a wound you will stay home for one
month and people say what why are you
sick you say is your finger this little
finger but it will collapse the whole
system and this was what was trying to
go on in in in in Era so it was a a
right time that all or most of the I
mean most of the
projects try to be inclusive in the team
first and then inclusive from the
research perspective and this
inclusivity has called us that when you
go for
research the community is such complex
like she was saying you know even in
bukina if you go to the north side you
get findings don't expect that you will
find the same thing from the souff so it
means that you need to have a
representative sample in all the process
if the variety has to be used for
different
communities or alternatively is you
focus in one community and you need to
be the most inclusive possible which is
first the value chain so usually we are
focusing
on Farmers a processors
Traders and because farmers are at the
same time consumers so and in the
farming perspective you have to be
inclusive because the point of view of
the woman who is cooking to appreciate
his specific variety is different from
the man who don't go next to the kitchen
but this is our culture if you see a man
in the kitchen there's a problem either
he's so modernized or he's
sick so these are yeah so it's it's not
usual that he's standing in the kitchen
trying to to cook and the Millet is not
getting ready and he's struggling no he
not so but when a woman is talking to
you about a variety she's made go in
details so we need to go on board with
the woman to understand the challenge
she's facing toward a specific crop like
Millet or Ci or S but also you need to
have the view of the man because he's
the head of the household and also I
mean we use not to interview a people
who are younger than 14 because you say
oh the founder would say that you are
doing child abuse talking about the
Farms but most of the time they doing
the work behind so having their point of
view is very crucial because most of
they not only consuming but also they
the hardworking people with the moms in
the farm without being seen properly
so the challenge sometimes either
Challenge from harvesting or Challenge
from picking the crops or the color is
changing if you're not on the F you
cannot appreciate it so the inclusivity
of the community in looking at what are
the preferences is very crucial for sure
it makes the work very long long process
because in the end of the day you find
yourself with a diversity of point of
view and then what we are trying to do
in that we have what we call the nice to
have
threats they must have threats which
means in in the end of the whole process
of collecting information in the in the
field and sometimes as well sorry to say
it because I consider also breeders as
part of my participants so I do
interview with them without telling them
what I'm looking for as as information
but when you are sharing back
information with them they realize that
some of these things are coming from me
but it makes sense in the whole thing
because they are completely part of the
work by being by working in the lab so
is very good to include them sometime as
participant in the in the survey so
having said so and when we have the M
have threat depending on the amount of
money because sometimes they cannot
breed for everything they will tell me
elyn I'm tired I say yes me too I'm
tired and I want you to tell me one two
three things I need to put and breath
for and I will tell him if if I tell you
the color yellow color is it enough he
say yes but I say it's not enough the
yellow you got in your mind might not be
the yellow the farmers is telling me so
you see how complex it is you may have
light yellow in your mind and you go and
breath light yellow and this perhaps
their totem is light yellow they want
dark yellow so even by saying the color
itself it's a big issue inside that you
have to investigate and in the end of
the day when you we we are able to have
the M have threat we have all to go on
the field and be able to to validate the
type of yellow yellowness I don't know
exist or the type of redness or Darkness
so that we are all even if I don't call
it yellow at least I know what it means
but this is still visible when you talk
about t this is and they will tell you
we want copy which t of like our local
variety I look at them and I'm sitting
collecting this data and I'm working in
my mind what is this kind of CI which
taste like the local variety so sometime
I need to tell them can you bring me a
handful of it at least if I have a
sample by talking about wish taste I can
show them this is it which means the bre
need to even tast it I don't know but at
least and these are some of the
information or the inclusiveness
strategy we are putting in place to be
able to move forward so I just want to
say that there is no one size fit all
because every single a I mean variety or
every single Community is a very complex
I mean community that you need to take
if in the end of the day we want it to
be successful there is no waste of time
in lab work and field work so that we
all move uh in the same same direction
and the last
thing little
bit the last thing well I leave it for
the question side if they ask question I
will add it yeah please thank you thank
you har uh in the project in Kenya we
are working on social inclusion uh
social inclusion is one of the
fundamental international human rights
where development agriculture
development project
need to for them to be inclusive they
need to bring on board the women the
youth and other marginalized groups
through a project supported by ELC we
are working with these other
marginalized groups and these are groups
which have never been thought about we
call them forgotten Farmers uh who who
are rarely targeted by development
programs we are working with the Widow
Farmers farmers who are widos we are
working with the farmers who are living
with HIV AIDS we are working with
Farmers living with disability we are
working with the farmers who are single
mothers under 35 years we are working
with the youth and we are also working
with the farmers who are caregivers of
infants now these groups uh even as in
our research program in our research
organization we've never reached them
but through ilc we are now having a
project which we are calling uh Last
Mile connectivity so that we can be able
to reach these groups with the
innovations that come from
breeders the context of these groups is
that they live in
marginalization they live in poverty
they live in
exclusion uh they've never been able to
use Innovations from breeders so in a
baseline survey that uh we we carried
out we wanted to understand uh their
situation and in order to improve their
livelihoods through the new
Innovations so uh the the Stak we are
working through a stakeholder platform
that involves public and private sector
actors in order to improve the
livelihood of these groups using new in
vers of high high ion Rich high iron and
zinc Rich
beans the bean is called Bean you can
Google you'll see it it has high iron
and zinc which is quite useful in terms
of nutrition for the type of groups that
I mentioned the other the other
Innovation is the finger Millet which in
that region in Kenya is very important
for porridge as well as you know the St
food then the final one is the the soam
so uh these groups through support by
ilc we've been able to disseminate the
three
varieties these varieties uh after
carrying out a rapid trait preferences
they wanted varieties which are climate
resilient meaning they are drought
tolerant they are early maturing and in
terms of beans they are gentle to the
stomach most people don't pref don't
like eating beans because they have
problems the stomach so we selected the
this variety because it is a flatlet
free and then in terms of in terms of
millet uh the the porridge is is quite
quite sweet the groups have already gone
through the first season they've grown
their varieties and we recently carried
out a food festival
and it was very encouraging to see how
products from breeders can be able to
transform uh the nutrition of these
disadvantaged groups in this food
festival we carried out it out with the
uh groups Farmers living the HIV and
their children and they had a meal
together of finger Millet porridge from
the Breeders as well as the high zinc
and ion Rich bean and uh
uh their feedback was that in terms of
the beans this was the best Bean that
they have ever uh had before compared to
the local varieties and also in terms of
SOA so uh this goes to underscore the
importance
of uh breeding programs when they
appropriately
Target uh the the market segments so we
think we think that that through this
stakeholder
program we are not only uh going to work
on issues of food and nutrition security
but also the issue of increasing the
voice of these groups in society because
by that through their their conditions
uh one of the things that makes them
discriminated is that they do not have a
platform to be able to increase their
voice in society so uh just want to say
that breeding is very important in
feeding the
future uh but it's only one part of the
equation the social scientists are very
important as well as the other the other
stakeholders to be able so that we all
work together in a a world that leaves
no one behind thank you
wow it's a beautiful
end I know we're out of time but I'd
love to take some questions until we get
kicked out of the room so I think
there's a class after this okay right
now yeah we do have one question on the
mind so maybe in the room one question
we yeah should we start with the room
any just need three more
hours so the question from Leah about
for
Sophie so could you provide more
information on the step taken by Naro uh
that ensure social economic aspects are
considered in a pre-breeding and early
breeding
programs within government funded
projects not donor funded
projects not Don government funding if
they are
in so all Government funding project is
that soal economic study considered in
the pre-reading stage any step to okay
thank you so much uh the government
funded
project I would say yes and
no because uh like in
Uganda uh the funding we get from
government for research is really
limited uh
most okay funding we get it from
donors however as I said before that uh
before we were considering that top
down uh research
approach uh
whereby uh like if breeders get little
money they have objectives like someone
will say I'm breeding um I want to
improve on yield and not looking at
other issues now for example if if you
breed if you want to improve on yield of
a certain crop variety you are
forgetting that there are also other
issues even if you take this variety
which is high yielding and uh maybe it
is very tall and you are taking it to
areas for example in the Eastern region
they like medium height varieties so
even believe it is high yielding because
the women are the one cultivating
someone will say that variety I can't do
what harest meaning you have to maybe
get men to help you and Men actually
will be enjoying their
bre they they're not bothered so as a
woman you have to provide food at
home uh so I can say
no when I follow that
argument I can also say yes because um
after working with you say actually
things are changing in that the approach
is also
changing for which is demand driven
whereby uh as social
Economist now at least we have a voice
before we used to work in
silos uh a breeder is working alone and
even socio Economist the
agronomists so you find that everything
is mixed up but right now uh now we are
working we are following the
interdisciplinary approach whereby we
come together and discuss how to handle
such issues so that I can say that it is
coming up and in case we get any
government funding we still have to
follow the the demand driven
approach thank
you I don't know answer that question
yes last
chance all right can you please help me
than
G this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu